hey folks welcome to the dark horse
podcast live stream number 103 that's
prime so don't go dividing it by stuff
it's not gonna work unless you choose
very carefully
that's right that is right that wasn't
that was an excellent way to introduce
us today um wow
wow is there a lot going on in the world
yep holy moly or mobile depending upon
your my eyes didn't just like almost
fall out of my head today they almost
shot their way across a
crowded street i have been so bug-eyed
with some of the stuff that's happening
i did notice them bulging when you
returned home yeah um well we'll get to
some of that today but um first some
logistics uh today we're starting late
um
and as announced last week we're not
gonna have a q a today so uh it's just
it's just this this first hour hour and
a half whatever it is
and then we'll be back next week at the
usually scheduled time at 12 30 pacific
a few other announcements to start and
then three ads and then we'll get right
into it we are going to be talking today
um
once we get through the logistics um a
bit about um science and not science and
uh truth and not truth
and some of the ways that you can keep
yourself healthy
and um
about
athletes and what they are and are not
allowed to do and a little bit about
giraffes which is how we here at
darkhorse pluralize giraffe we say drops
we do thank you colin for that upgrade
to our pronunciation indeed yes that is
our our friend and former student colin
uh who uh alerted us many many years ago
to the fact that really it ought to be
pronounced drops drops yes he also
alerted us to the glory of brassicas as
salad
makings but yeah i mean we already were
eating brassicas but not enough of them
but yeah he was he he was vegan he may
well be still i'm not sure um but he at
one point uh was
uh talking about the paucity of other of
other clades of of leafy vegetables in
the salads that were available at the
farmer's market it was just a brassica
heavy and he was he thought that that
was just a bit of a bit too much oh he
was anti-brassica no he wasn't
anti-breast he just felt like it had
been overdone overdone
the
oversaturation of the farmers market
salads with brassicas and drops are two
of the many contributions that colin has
made to our thinking
well he also helped raise our children
he was their their manny for a while oh
he hated that term though he did not not
like that term all the more reason to
use it
sorry colin if you are watching i have
no idea
colin has such a marvelous sense of
humor i i do not hesitate to chide him
because he chides right back he does
yeah but he's not able to he can't reach
through the camera and shake either of
us by our lapels right well once we're
all on meta then he'll be able to
uh
we're not even going to talk about
matters no we're not no no no no no um
we are going to talk about why why were
we talking about colin um oh drugs
giraffes yes um
johns hopkins is not making any sense um
some athletes are the giraffes
well the drops are dead so um they're
not making any sense at all anymore uh
there's a lot of other things we might
get to but probably not we have a lot to
talk about today we're in sort of a a
silly mood because what are you gonna do
what are you gonna do when the world
goes completely insane on you here we
are talking to you and we are grateful
that you are here and listening or
watching and listening
and um i was saying just before we
started that i am
so grateful
to brett for not just
being here
for allowing us to travel through this
crazy
life side by side but for actually
seeing
we each see the world to our own sets of
eyes and we can compare what we see and
uh we are
we are seeing the same things
the same hard to believe stuff yeah but
when my eyes bug out and almost
fling themselves across busy
intersections
so too it turns out have your eyes been
bugging out quite independently in some
other location
right
wow okay so um announcements first
though again no q a today
um with regard to our book a
hunter-gatherer's guide to the 21st
century
some people have been asking about
excuse me the possibility of getting
signed books lately and we were
certainly hoping that we would be able
to do live events and we'd be available
for for signings and of course that
isn't happening it still may happen in
the spring but that's a long way off and
who knows what the world will look like
by then
uh so one possibility and so i'll just
i'll just put this out there um is that
some
awesome portland area independent
bookseller would be willing to associate
with such abominable people such as
ourselves
and um and and
buy books as they were in stock and we
would sign them and then anyone who
wanted to sign copy we've been hearing
from people who are interested in having
signed copies as holiday gifts uh could
order from that from that bookstore
which would then help that bookstore in
sales and would also allow you to get a
signed copy uh so if if there were i
mean there are
several
amazing independent booksellers here in
portland but we don't know if any of
them are willing to associate with such
people as ourselves so who you called
obama abominable
and because we are in the pacific
northwest that would make us abominable
rain men
yes yes yes
yes
sorry
this is what we're like in the afternoon
this is what we're like after our eyes
have exploded from our heads yes
um so get in if you know of an
independent bookseller that might or you
or are one even better um
contact
our darkhorse monitor
darkhorse.moderator gmail.com we'd even
take a dependent bookseller
i'm actually done with the dependent
entities that appear to be independent
i'm
i'm through with those i see yeah yeah
now if it was just you know if that's if
that's what was on its uh all right
shingle out front you know depend fully
owned and operated by
um i would at least be interested in the
the honesty the transparency but i will
revise my statement we will accept an
independent bookseller or a codependent
bookseller
but no dependent book sellers so
dependent on with other book sellers
presumably oh okay sure yeah yeah well
maybe publish i mean that's the way it
is right publishers that would be a
natural codependent yeah absolutely
absolutely um if you're watching on
youtube consider switching to odyssey if
you're watching right now as i'm saying
these words uh you'll find the chat live
on odyssey and not on youtube
considering
wow consider joining our patreons please
last month last month wow this is going
to be rough
last week we had our private um two-hour
q a um which you can find at my patreon
which is always a lot of fun and brett
had one of his patreon conversations
this morning we'll have the next one
tomorrow morning those always happen
usually happen barring on other things
that are scheduled the first saturday
and sunday of the month and our private
q a happens the last sunday of the month
so consider joining us there we really
do appreciate the support
um oh and natural selections which is my
sub stack uh has
got some
additional attention
uh last time as we talked about i wrote
about vitamin d deficiency and we're
gonna be talking a little bit more about
that about that today and you're going
to probably talk about that with some
external guests soon some some excellent
people with whom we
have now made contact um i also uh last
week posted on halloween on zombies that
we find in the in the natural world
non-human zombies but
are really the zombification by fungus
of things like ants and caterpillars
and my post this upcoming tuesday is
going to be
less political in zombies it's going to
be about why we shouldn't be medically
transitioning children so i'm just gonna
sort of steer away from the storm and
yeah and go there for the other story
and yeah into quite quite a different
kind of storm but one
um to completely mix my metaphors uh one
with hills upon which i will i will die
if i need to a storm of hills yes storm
of hills yes star pills okay uh without
further ado we have three ads this week
we are as always very grateful to our
sponsors our sponsors this week are soul
which is new to us relief band and four
sigmatic
soul is a brand new sponsor to us
um they are a sustainable orthopedic
footwear company now we already for
those of you who watch regularly or
listen
already have one shoe sponsor
vivobarefoot and we speak about them
with
great affection why would we accept a
second given that we've been telling you
and we actually really do only accept
sponsors
uh whose products we back well this
company is quite different from the
other and we honestly really love them
both
vivo barefoot specifically aims to give
you the sense of being barefoot um in
your shoes whereas seoul with both their
shoes and their footbeds in particular
which is which i mean their shoes have
their footbeds in them bring structure
back but in the right way
and uh the shoes by seoul are are
utterly beautiful um our two boys in
particular have been basically living in
their sole shoes since we um since we
got the delivery month or two ago
and they're gorgeous and they get
comments um when they when they go to
school they're hanging out with a
totally better class of people now
that's not true but it could be yeah
yeah okay
yeah seoul s-o-l-e has created a foot
bed that is as in a great place to rest
your soul that is affordable
customizable and improves people's
everyday foot comfort
millions of customers have already raved
about this product and two-thirds of
seoul customers have two or more pairs
of these foot beds
um and it's also created its own
recycling program recork in which they
collect and upcycle used wine corks to
make their products
uh record has collected over 125 million
wine stoppers that get ground down and
reuse into the company's own foot beds
and shoes that is really cool
like i said our two boys um both
teenagers handsome young men are wearing
these handsome shoes basically all the
time now our sense from them is this
they do take some getting used to which
soul itself acknowledges um that they
are they are made for the actual
structure of the arch and the footbed of
your foot
or the or the shape of your foot
um so they take a little getting used to
they feel unusual at first not painful
but once you get used to them they
provide great support for your feet and
they look great and um that's absolutely
true these these shoes look they're
beautiful and if you're looking for foot
beds to make shoes you already own that
you already enjoy
be healthy for your feet try their foot
beds seriously try them
seoul has an amazing offer for
first-time customers of 50
off through your soul.com
darkhorse so you can try seoul for
yourself that's
your
y-o-u-r-s-o-l-e dot com
darkhorse we're so confident they are so
confident that you will love them that
they also offer a 90-day money-back
guarantee it's very hard to go wrong
with this offer
so the darkhorse offer of 50 off through
your soul.com darkhorse is applicable to
all items on the sole store be it foot
beds or footwear
our second sponsor all right relief band
now relief band contrary to what some
people think is not a understudy musical
act it is a product to help you with
nausea thank you we should talk yeah i
was thank you for clarifying that yeah
we should talk a little bit about nausea
under ancient circumstances and some
modern ones nausea is generally a useful
signal that something is off for example
to have eaten something that you should
not have
in modernity we still need to track our
bodily sensitivities we should not
always choose to simply erase discomfort
like nausea whenever we feel it that
said some of modernity creates nausea
that does no good at all travel sickness
for instance can be agonizing and relief
would be lovely enter relief band relief
band is an anti-nausea wristband that
has been clinically proven to relieve
and prevent nausea uh with associated
with motion sickness anxiety migraines
chemotherapy and more relief band is 100
drug free and can be used as long as you
need it developed over 20 years ago it
is the only over-the-counter wearable
device that has been used in hospitals
and oncology clinics to treat nausea and
vomiting
we asked a friend to try it out here's
her testimonial
i have you i have had nausea on a nearly
daily basis from both anxiety and the
need to take regular medication relief
band relieves my nausea in less than
three minutes without side effects i was
experiencing from anti-nausea medication
it has entirely changed my life for the
better
as you are getting for a road trip or a
boat trip or expecting nausea for other
reasons consider relief band which has
an exclusive
offer just for dark horse listeners
go to
reliefband.com and use the promo code
darkhorse to receive 20 off plus free
shipping and no questions asked 30-day
money-back guarantee
so head to relief ban
r-e-l-i-e-f-b-a-n-d
dot com and use our promo code darkhorse
for 20 off plus free shipping
finally our third sponsor for today is
one uh which you will already be
familiar with it's four sigmatic
a wellness company known for its
delicious mushroom coffee as well as
protein powders that contain mushrooms
sounds weird i say that every time i
read this ad but i it continues to sound
weird to me and it's maybe sounds
off-putting and i was skeptical as i've
said before but i've been drinking their
mushroom coffee lately and it's really
good
four sigmatics mushroom coffee contains
organic fair trade single origin arabica
coffee with both lion's mane and chaga
mushrooms
the four cinematics ground mushroom cup
with lion's mane adds a little something
some crispness and focus it's delicious
just like your favorite coffee dark and
nutty
all four sigmatic products are organic
vegan and gluten free and every patch is
third party lab tested to ensure its
purity and safety just want to say with
regard to its gluten-freeness you as
we've talked about before need it to be
gluten-free and in this context i have
to wonder how would they even get gluten
into it
like where would the gluten come from
and yet yeah this needs to be stated now
because gluten shows up in so many
products that aren't actually what they
what they appear to be so it's organic
vegan gluten free four sigmatic has a
100 money back guarantee love every sip
or get your money back
so we've got an exclusive offer with
four sigmatic and their best-selling
mushroom coffee for dark horse listeners
get up to 40 off plus free shipping on
mushroom coffee bundles to claim this
deal go to 4sigmatic.com darkhorse
that's f o u r
s i g m a t i c dot com slash darkhorse
and fuel your productivity and
creativity with some delicious mushroom
coffee
that is it for ants
all right
now we are ready to talk about um
about other things eye bulging things
yeah do you want to start or should i
you go right ahead
um
only a couple of hours ago we became
aware of um
a conversation with francis collins
who's the head of the nih on lex
friedman's podcast
and we've both listened but we really
have had very little time to to
think
carefully through the various ways to
respond i have
pages of notes that i am not going to to
riff on here um but for a couple of
points and you wanted to just say
something about one of the points
yes i want to uh
to do that i i should say i have not
gotten 100 through it yet i'm okay uh
probably an hour into it yeah i have um
i literally was not able to listen to
the last two minutes yet but i feel like
i got the chest
um and lots and lots maybe the punchline
is in the last two minutes
yeah maybe so
um
so francis collins is the he's been for
12 years the head of the nih spanned um
three different presidencies
um he is as the head of the nih of
course the employer of the boss of the
heads of all of the the sub agencies at
the nih including the niaid
which is the agency that that fauci
leads
and
without going into all of the details on
the various claims in the podcast this
may not seem as strong but one of the
things that colin says in this podcast
is that in addition to stars kovy 2
quote we have another epidemic in this
country it's the loss of the anchor of
truth
and
he of course is suggesting that it is uh
people who are questioning the
pronouncements that are coming out of
organizations like the niad and the cdc
and the who
who are losing touch with the
quote-unquote anchor of truth
but given how many
how many untruths and illusions and
slights of hand
that he engages in in this in this
conversation it would seem to me that he
is um exactly the person who is
contributing to the epidemic to which he
is referring
yeah it's perfectly ironic it is it is
perfectly
i'm just i'm going to try to stay cool
here i
the other thing that i wanted to
specifically mention since we don't have
um
i'm
sorry
i'm not i'm i take back what i said no
no no this is not this is not on you uh
we decided that uh i should not be let
completely off leash today because um i
would i don't think it might be fun to
watch and i'd probably be um some
riveting and maybe a little cathartic
for me but i don't think it would
necessarily be the best use of our
platform
near the end of the conversation uh
collins uses a metaphor of being a
midwife in this process and i actually
did not have time to go back and um
remind myself of whether or not he's
talking about being a midwife in the
process of of covid of the coveted
response or um of the entire um his
entire time at nih but regardless really
there are enough other things that he's
done at nih that um that no matter which
one of those two things he's referring
to
this um
at the point that he called himself a
midwife i think i almost punched a tree
i was out walking well uh while
listening and um he's actually i think a
better
metaphor than midwife uh would be that
he's he's the doctor who comes in as a
woman is um getting close to being able
to give birth um perfectly normally and
you know it's hard and it's dangerous
and uh the fact that we're bipedal makes
it uh makes it more dangerous and more
difficult the fact that we've got giant
brains all of this is true and um
uh medical intervention has saved babies
lives and women's lives but um most
births don't require it and he's
actually rather than like a midwife um
who is simply facilitating what was
already going to happen and helping it
along he's more like the doctor who
forces full medicalization
of birth he drugs the mom and he cuts
her open and he rips the baby out and
then he drags the baby away from the mom
maybe doesn't let baby near the bomb um
for a little while and then and then
when the baby uh doesn't attach at the
breast or is otherwise a little impaired
for having had this incredibly traumatic
birth experience he blames the mother
that's what he's like not a midwife he's
like that doctor
and this is um
just how how dare he call himself a
midwife really well i actually kind of
want to steal man his position oh go
yeah go for it now my thought is that
what we have is a completely
disastrous
public health policy in response to this
pandemic has been from the beginning and
collins has been in a position to do
something right about it which he has
failed to do again and again
it is
not as much
um
his catastrophe as it is directly
anthony fauci's collins is fauci's boss
and so
i would say
that um
fauci is more like the mother of this
crisis
and
collins
it's a midwifed crisis let's put it that
way
midwifed crisis you don't get it
oh no
my joke is swollen flat midwife crisis
oh oh see all right yeah i don't like it
though i i get it now but i don't like
it i mean hey um
i came in the door yeah i'm full of
adrenaline right now but um
but i also i guess i don't um
you know
midwives have been vilified you know not
not so recently like you know by the
time we were young adults i think
midwives were coming back into fashion
it was sort of understood that the
medical it was beginning to be
understood that medicalization of birth
had been
way overdone and that midwives having
been you know pushed out in favor of
high intervention
high credential doctors was uh was maybe
not the right move
but i guess i don't want to um
neither of them
neither of them have been midwife-like
right right no i i i mean but this is
you know this is this is
this is why some people don't like puns
right it's like oh okay i get what you
were trying to do but no no some people
don't like puns i know nobody likes puns
unless you're making them right yeah
dick alexander used to say that the uh
the person who was the butt of the
the pun was the person listening to it
um
that's good yeah that's probably right
that's a very insightful guy um but
anyway yeah so all right this this
midwife thing is a way that people
distance themselves from responsibility
you know it was happening anyway and and
it's sort of falsely humble but in this
case actually he deserves responsibility
and responsibility for what is in effect
an upside down response where we've
missed virtually every opportunity we
had to do something useful and embraced
all sorts of things that don't make any
sense
and
um anyway it was very disturbing i mean
he does
appear
to be
guileless
and yet almost everything he says in at
least the first hour of this podcast
strikes me as
distorted warped misleading it was it
was a remarkable display there's a lot
of very precise language uh that is
delivered as if it just occurred
yeah it's a very precise language is a
is a good way of of putting it um
and a fair amount of cfa i noticed
throughout what's up uh cover fouchy's
ass um he did a lot and he did it about
as well as a transparent miniskirt
you could see right through oh no yeah i
know oh no
okay i would like the audience to
recognize that that image that is now in
all of our heads was not put there by me
i didn't do it didn't do it wouldn't
have done it i wouldn't have done it you
know the funny thing is i said it
without having the image in my head and
now you have forced me
to see that i don't think that this is
my you know i i'm i'm neither midwife
nor dimed i'm just i don't feel like
maybe we should not belabor the point
good one well done
yeah no you have no responsibility
you're like the the 60s husband in the
waiting room
handing out cigars to random strangers
look what i'm doing
okay exactly
i should say
a putative father in the waiting room
ah
did you want
were you going somewhere else no no
really i think i was i think it was
there you didn't want to i thought you
maybe wanted to say something about that
you would said oh yeah oh uh you you
were done with your point all right so
we could move on to that uh that point
so one of the things that he does here
is he
attempts to cover fouchy on this issue
of gain of function where of course
fauci lied directly to congress with
cameras running
some of us saw it right away you can
check my tweet from
uh from that moment and which
point i said this is just a flat out lie
no but brett
i mean my eyeglasses are going to
function so yeah what so so collins does
this amazing thing here which is he
basically argues that gain of function
is effectively meaningless because
virtually everything that we do that
works is a gain of function so that's
not what we science types mean by gain
of function we mean something very
specific and so narrow that you almost
couldn't possibly meet the definition
and then he tells us more or less where
the bodies are buried literally in this
case
what he says is effectively look
gain of function in the regulated sense
only applies to human pathogens and
because we're talking about bat viruses
you know yeah we're not talking about
gain of function in the gain of function
sense although we may be talking about a
gain of a function no it's very highly
regulated i mean there's only been three
uh influenza viruses in the last several
years that have been authorized
and therefore right and this is uh
nonsense and really its purpose is to
lead you to believe that there's some
very technical discussion that you are
not qualified to understand and
therefore fauci has been simply
insisting on a technical definition that
you couldn't possibly care about and uh
you know rand paul has been going after
him based on common parlance and it's
like all some kind of scientific
misunderstanding it does depend on what
the definition of is is it it it sure is
um
yeah yeah
it's similar level of definitional games
games yes games uh in which you know
that reference to um clinton being
impeached in
1996 whatever it was
um you know the only thing at stake was
actually his presidency which to him was
obviously incredibly important but um
people weren't gonna die over it
um but in this case this these
definitional games are um of far greater
impact tremendous impact and they are a
matter of responsibility so uh he also
does a lot of stuff you know he makes
the standard
play he says
that
although a lab leak is
possible it's very unlikely based on
exactly zero evidence of course
and actually
lex asks him if um
uh if this is a matter of science if we
will ever if there's any way that we
will actually ever know about the origin
and
colin says well yes it's quite possible
we will know and alex asks him how
and he says well if we find the
intermediate so basically the point is
he has set up a circumstance in which
only one side of the equation is
testable if it turns out to be a
natural origin then we can prove it and
there's nothing that can prove the other
direction and so and and the whole thing
is just nonsense because we've we can
see
in
the uh the grant application that was
recently revealed by eco health alliance
where they wanted to enhance pathogens
the entire argument for the research
program involves enhancing pathogens so
we can understand how they work before
the pandemic strikes us from nature so
the the whole thing is nonsense he's
just creating a false story and through
the entire thing he strikes this
um this
uh stance in which he is the beleaguered
scientist forced to engage an ignorant
public and yes that's his cross to bear
and he will do so willingly so long as
in the end the public comes around to
the pronouncements of the public health
authorities who have of course been
right from the beginning when in fact
they've been wrong again and again and
again and again and they've been
revealed to be hiding things again and
again who most especially fouchy again
and again and again and so why is
anybody listening to this guy
why is anybody listening to this guy he
is lying into a camera in order to
mislead you back into a story that has
fallen apart around him
yeah
and uh
there are a lot of
those examples in this conversation um
which
we're not going to pursue here
right right we will
allow our eyes to bulge privately
um
good for now yep
all right uh i did actually want to
segue to the next thing we were going to
talk about uh with uh
one additional thing uh that that he
said that collins the head of the nih
said
in this conversation um he is asked what
can be done to stop the pandemic
and he says and again i'm not quoting
here but the full extent of his answer
is like again not a quote but the full
extent of what he says to stop the
pandemic in this country and you know
and and here as elsewhere alex does a
good job of saying yes but you know what
about
but the full extent of his answer is
vaccinate everyone
including children
socially distance
wear masks
that
is
it
that is the full extent of the answer
that he provides for how we can stop
this pandemic
he must know that's not true
he must know he has been the head of the
national institutes of health
for 12 years okay
how else
can we actually control this pandemic
how can individuals actually take
control of their own health
besides getting vaccinated and wearing
masks and socially distancing which are
the three things and and making sure
that their children get vaccinated if
they have young children these are the
only things that he says individuals can
do in order to help control this
pandemic no he is wrong and he knows
he's wrong
eat real food
move your body supplement with vitamin d
if any of the following things are true
for you if it is winter where you live
if you live at high latitudes if you are
obese if your skin is dark if you are
sick in any way but especially with any
of the comorbidities for covid
there are a tremendous number of things
that people can do to actually take
control of their own health
and by doing so the outcomes for covid
the chances that you will get it and the
chances that you will get really sick
from it go down dress dramatically
dramatically another thing that he says
in this conversation which is not true
that um that your that your health
doesn't have an effect on
on covet outcome it's it's it's a it's
dead wrong and he knows it um
so um we talked about vitamin d last
week i wrote a piece and we've been
having conversations with people and
we're going to continue to talk about
vitamin d because i feel like vitamin d
is the failure of the public health
officials to talk about vitamin d
is pointing us yet again as other things
have before to something being very very
very rotten in the state of denmark as
it were
let's go back a ways though
early in the pandemic uh and you you can
inter-intervene here anytime you want i
may just i may start ranting
um hopefully it doesn't require
intervention interjection i think is
sufficient
as long as we can just keep it to a dull
roar yeah
please oh my god
um i got you here we got zach in the
room we got fairfax sitting right off
camera i'm in really good company guys
i'm feeling okay if intervention should
become necessary you have um
you've set me up to do it by wearing
lapels i have yeah they're they're kind
of they're loose though they think they
give it's not the usual kind of lip
palette i can work with it okay good
good to know
good to know elastic lapels you can
brent weinstein i can work with elastic
lapels
actually that probably works better in a
cartoon but yeah yeah
to support us like this video subscribe
to the channel and consider writing a
comment and because 1984 has captured
2021 click the link in the description
to see the full clip on odyssey
[Music]
you